welcome to this video haga again having
the sky and playing him so often really
amazing is he playing this weird stuff
again no it's not okay this kind of
thing yeah I don't want a complicated
position let's keep it simple okay yeah
let's let's attack let's check this okay
so it's basically saying I don't care
about the dark squares you can have them
ok I'm going to attack then Reggie 5
simply yeah come on let's do that okay
so maybe just just over there is good
night f5 as a as a defense
i Knight a5 is quite okay probably okay
it's hard to to keep the center in this
position anyway trying for 94 yeah i
played this all a bit a bit too quickly
up this is not really good I guess Queen
a form for pin not really helping
yeah this night coming to a fire this is
really annoying them just a good piece
oops okay let me see how can I what
about playing some paint some good moves
once in a while I could try getting and
getting the Bishop to g5 would be
actually quite a good idea that's some
some way to do that maybe start with
that I don't know you know what it looks
we add the whole thing yeah me plea me
playing 1.e4 sometimes looks like really
weird
covering batumi as intending for sure d
to g5 if i can really get down it is not
that bad maybe and really I know that
f3s is loose and stuff but I thought 94
was much more was much more threatening
to be honest okay so he's intending to
to do some evil stuff via evil stuff on
this diagonal okay rook was a liability
anyway so let's see
so I now Bishop to g5 I guess right
Knight e5 rookie five check on edge
one-half noisy one at least check ok so
this check here is not wearing a man too
much Jack and we are now to f4 probably
intending is 6 cm I don't know probably
i'm lost but it is at least tricky yeah
that's it's an ID i am but i have quincy
for at least i have 94 94 with the idea
to jump to h6
yeah that that's at least that is that
is an idea I come on let's start it
start with this King age seven is there
something else and I can give the check
all the time it's there something better
maybe not check this check six you will
take em Quincy for Quincy for rugby
seven that's not really a win there any
way to get to get to the kind 196 prolly
not Knight f3 king age seven ah ok andy
sixx i need to play e6 now attacking the
Queen when when when the bishop is
protected this is the chemo
and this will be very very very
dangerous I cannot defend that is giving
away the queen but I think this is
fascism just that's the quickest way to
finish him off this is going to make
going to be made King g8 I'll take him
Jack and queen d 6 with checkmate coming
check checkmate yeah that was a
full-scale swindle I mean positionally
strategically I was totally busted
playing some really weird stuff yes
starting here i think in here this is
probably still ok and then i started to
play really really weird stuff yeah I
like it this kind of maneuvers that
probably is not good at all and I think
like us in excellent shape week on
towards the center I am not really
threatening much I think one point was
he went with g4 I thought why not
something i'd probably it is also just
good but i thought that maybe a night to
device is also yeah i understand yes if
you look at this this isn't this isn't
that clear and now Bishop g5 bishop f6
ok this one yeah and now I went with
with this this kind of desperation
sacrifice but ok it is a draw the comp
says this is a draw honey it finds some
perpetual ok and here let's see what
happened here check check Queen f4 and
now what is the draw here and what not
Queen B 5 is a draw okay Jack King here
and now 9085 year Wow now this is
winning for what so then how is he
drawing he actually Queen B seven Queen
B seven maybe I don't know isn't this
very dangerous for him and evaluation is
climbing up to why do wynia this is
already a very dangerous attack yeah
tough tough to analyze now to a
conclusion d3d three losses due to
nighty fires and now is six it took me I
took me one time to find it but here
here why do I himself definitely he has
no defense this was even chat Jack even
even just this made chance late coming
it was cute not a really great game but
first but funny funny end with the quite
good attack okay thanks for watching